all right guys we're gonna talk about
the prostate there's a lot of false
information about prostate number one
this this theory out there that they say
that too much testosterone especially
the most powerful type of testosterone
which is DHT causes in a large prostate
well if that was true then why is it
that the certain doctors use DHT as a
therapy to shrink the prostate it's not
true that too much prostate have too
much testosterone causes enlargement of
the prostate simply because as you age
testosterone goes down so why would you
have an enlarged prostate if you get
older it's basically the estrogen
testosterone and estrogen work together
when you lower testosterone you raise
estrogen estrogen is an anabolic hormone
it makes things enlarged in a female it
will make a fibroid tumor okay and a
male body enlarge the prostate so if you
have prostate enlargement it's because
you have too much estrogen now where
does estrogen come from well first of
all your body can make it or it can come
from the foods that you eat the glands
that make estrogen in a male body are
the adrenal glands so there's also your
own fat can make estrogen so the fatter
you are the more estrogen you can have
and so we must reduce estrogen okay a
couple ways to do it
is avoid food that has estrogen in it
you have hormone free meets all the GMO
foods genetically modified soy corn beet
sugar that are in the grocery store that
are not labeled they are very estrogenic
because they're loaded with a pesticide
that mimics estrogen so unless you're
doing organic food you're getting a lot
of GMO food which is then going to
increase estrogen amounts now estrogen
it causes cancer
it causes prostate cancer
that causes cancer of the cervix and
females and breast tissue and thyroid
cancer it's pretty nasty so luckily
there are foods that naturally detoxify
things that turn into cancer and
estrogen itself and it's called
cruciferous foods that would be like the
kale that broccoli or the brussel
sprouts the cabbage the radish arugula
you need to start eating those okay if
you have a hard time eating those do
regular vegetables and you can enhance
it with like a cruciferous concentrate
okay you can use that as well and this
has all the cruciferous with some other
ones but if you have a prostate problem
I'll go take probably six of these a day
okay so that's one thing you can do the
other thing you can do is take seek help
in the morning take one one tablet
seek help will also reduce estrogen it's
really good for the thyroid too and it's
good for if you have cold feet okay so
number two or reduce aroma taste what is
a Roma taste that is an enzyme that's
made by your body that converts the
testosterone that you have left in
estrogen great so that's that's nothing
that's happening to is that we're
actually converting testosterone and
making your body's are making more
estrogen that's crazy
so having a lot of estrogen is very
carcinogenic it's it's going to increase
your risk factors for cancer so there
are even medications that are aromatase
inhibitors okay to fix cancer or to kill
cancer but you want to use the natural
things that are aroma taste inhibitors
and the best one that I know of is
stinging nettle root stinging nettle
root is an a great plant or a root that
you can get as a tablet form and you
want to actually double the dosage it's
great also as an anti-inflammatory it's
great to prevent hair loss so this is
like an awesome thing for the prostate
consider it better than some of the saw
palmetto stuff that you would get in
some supplements but if you have
prostate this is the one you need to get
and you'll start noticing something like
it changes okay if you get up to pee at
night that should improve with the
insulin correction as well because
that's really a one of the side effects
from insulin is excessive urination at
night so as you fix the blood sugars you
also pee less so it may come from
prostate enlargement or it could come
from the blood sugar issues okay hope
this helped apply it and I will see you
in the next video